right well welcome welcome so much i'm
very very happy this is a dream to be
in your house
[Music]
my wife is my son because although
i feel so happy and fulfilled with my
life
and i feel every day is a blessing
i just want that he has a different
opportunity hey what's up my name is
samuel leeds this is winners on a
wednesday where every single week i
interview one of my success students
who has become financially free by
investing in property as a direct result
of our training programs
this week i am with angelica she is
financially free she came on the
training
two years ago she's had an absolute
whale of a time of the last couple of
years
has got five rent to rent has got four
properties that she's bought mostly hmos
is making around about two and a half
thousand pounds a month clean
profit which is an average salary and
she's making that
through recurring income in property
angelica great to have you on wins on a
wednesday
thank you very much i'm very very happy
to be here so you are from originally
from mexico
yes and life was a little bit different
back then though right
very different talk to me a little bit
about your upbringing about your
childhood
uh well i was born in tijuana which is
the border with united states
and i was a seven year old
from a very poor neighborhood in in
mexico
i was living in a 13 square meters
wooden house with a double bed where
my family and i would sleep on my my
little sister my mom
and my dad and we had to sleep the other
way around so
we could all fit and you know
a lot of different things but it was
very very very
very different we used to have a
composting this
one of these composting toilets with no
water pipes or drains
and on paved streets and um
the very good thing is that my mom was
always challenged
us and always making us uh
believe that this was something temporal
and and gave us all the
the education the best she could uh
to for us to overcome that yeah and when
did you come to the uk then
uh in 2010 okay cool
so so when you came down to england what
what were you what were you doing what
was your first job here in the uk
well by that but that time because of my
mom i got to study in one of the
most successful universities in mexico
private
i had a 90 scholarship but still i was
uh
in a very nice university and then i was
working in a multinational company in
mexico that i
also work here so i was working for
around 11 years in a very
successful and driven company and then
in 2015
i decided to to leave that yeah so 2015
and from your you've always been a
pretty
pretty good with money so you in your
job you were saving saving saving and
you were also investing and you am i
thinking you bought two properties from
2008 to 2015.
yes well i actually bought those
properties just
before i left because when i decided to
leave the company
i i kind of made a strategy and a plan
just not to drop the job so i said i
really need to make sure that my visa is
in place because i depended
on this job to have my to be able to
live here
yeah and i really need to have a house
because if i am self-employed or or if i
have a company
my knowledge was that i wouldn't be able
to get a mortgage
so i worked very hard the last year and
and when i took the decision that i
didn't want to work
in any company that wasn't maybe
mine or or it wasn't my passion i
i literally worked through those steps
to get my first property
and then leave the company and then it
was kind of by accident that i became a
landlord with nothing
a lot of knowledge i refinanced and then
i got another
flat yeah but it was a little bit you
know
not a great beginning but why was it
because because it's interesting because
when we met in 2018 you'd already
got a little bit of experience in
property but you said that it had kind
of gone not that great
there'd been some problems and talk to
me a little bit about that because i
think
you know i think it's i think property
investing is a business
and i think that if you're going to go
into property you should treat it really
seriously get the training
understand what you're doing have a
business plan but most people that get
into properties stumble into it or they
do it accidentally
and i think that when you do that things
can go wrong so
i mean what what happened look if i had
treated
my property business as i was treated as
i was treating
my work maybe all had been different
in my work i i come from from sales
and i negotiated and i you know
read other people's mind and when i went
into property i went
a little bit in a rush to get the first
property it doesn't matter
like i wasn't making a full analysis of
the numbers i was more or less
evaluating the area but
i i was not really negotiating
i was like okay this more or less sounds
good and
i think i left a lot of money
in the uh deal
because i couldn't negotiate left a lot
of money on the table
because that's the thing if you know how
to negot if you negotiate well in
property
you can easily knock off 10 20 30 grand
so when people say oh training's
expensive
it's like well actually if you know how
to just negotiate
a deal straight away you can save 10 20
30 grand so it's
you've got to look at the return on
investment uh would you would you agree
definitely so i i didn't negotiate well
enough i didn't know
the you know the obligations as a
landlord
and i didn't know how to maximize
those investments either because it was
like renting it
as a single instead of applying for a
hmo license all of that i i
come to learn after because that's
another thing you were renting it out as
a single let
but then when we met and we did some
training you're thinking actually
that could work as a hmo yeah and then
years later
you turned into a hmo is that correct
and suddenly you're making
a lot more money on it and it's like all
these years you could have been making
that extra money yeah
you know the amount of money you lost so
when we made 2015
no sorry 2018 you were teaching um
brazilian dancing martial art what's it
called capoeira
i said that very wrong no you you were
actually one of the person that said oh
right
it's not an easy word yeah well my
stepmom is brazilian so i should
probably i should probably speak
a bit more portuguese well i can give
you a capoeira lesson there we have it
the artichoke property you teach me
portuguese
and you teach you're a teacher you're
training yourself you do you teach kids
how to
how to how to do that how to dance how
to martial arts
um and i think that's one of the reasons
why we got on so well because of your
um discipline and some of the traits
that you have as a trainer are probably
similar to
to maybe what i have as a trainer as
well so what happened when we met 2000
and also when we met how are things
going financially were they going good
were they going bad like where where
were you at
when we met i had left a very
comfortable job with a nice salary and a
nice lifestyle to
do what i love and then i realized that
what i love wasn't paying my bills
so when we met i was uh struggling every
month to just
you know not struggling that would be a
lie but
just paying my bills and and kind of
managing
just to pay the bills and nothing else
yeah and working really hard for it
yeah um and so i went into the into the
crash course and
i felt you know like a life-changing
experience with so much content
i i am a salesperson so i'm just to be
sold i have no problem with that because
that's you know i i did that for for
many years
but for me that was a very
uh great content that i got
i had done to buy my my first house and
my second house i went into a lot of
free training a lot and my rule was
learn first apply what you learn and
then decide what education you take
after
yeah but for me i received so much
content
and and not only about property but
about mindset and about
well it was just wow that i ended up
just saying like you know what
just by the tv and it was one of the
best
decisions for me because uh
just because if i only had done the
crash course with all the things that
was going on in my life
going out of a very long seven-year
relationship where
it was ending and then meeting a new
person and in four months
of going out with him getting married
and all excitement and
going out to san francisco for a moment
and coming back i had
forgotten that i had like a mindset
mindset change and everything because
something happens in an event and then
you go home and
and if it's not a constant reminder it
takes a little bit of time
because it's been years and years and
years of your own mindset
so for me having committed to the dfe
and then
having the you know that uh
course as a reminder and all the
all the knowledge uh it was the thing
that make
the most change yeah and i think from
what you're saying about the crash
course
um of course every every every business
sells you know unless you've got no
product you're gonna have to sell
your product so we have training
programs like the deal finding
extravagance the dfe which we sell
but my philosophy is serve before you
sell so if you're going to sell
something
give loads of value first so the crash
course we give
so much content so much strategy so much
teaching
and we don't spend much time at all
selling like it's uh
i think i think we sell twice maybe uh
on the first day on the second day for
about 15 20 minutes
it's just a quick hey here's an offer
boom boom boom but you
feel so much value was added and so much
uh significance that i was literally
running
yeah let me sign up yeah because cause i
guess my job
is to uh but when people say samuel
sells people dreams i'm like
my job is to sell people on the fact
that they can do it i'm gonna i am gonna
sell you a dream but then i'm also gonna
then work with you and help you
and give you the tools to then go make
that dream a reality
um so which is which is which is what
happened after the crash course with
with you
so what happened to the deal finding
extravaganza talk me through that whole
because that was three days
yes taught me through what happened um
well i was
uh learning in more depth
what we saw in the crash course and
obviously the great thing is that
then i have uh time to go through and
have
questions and then i i got my questions
i got my set of
uh paperwork that i could start working
on so as soon as i
i left the well actually during that
course i was making calls and saying
like should we set up a company and we
can do this and we can do this
now one of my biggest mistake was
wanting to make
everything you know like i i went out of
there wanting to do
loa service accommodation hmos deal
sourcing because
everything is everything is great and i
think that if you implement it
you will do it but for me it took time
to
to and took a lot of mistakes to
actually
know what i wanted because i started i
formed this company with two other
friends
and we started doing loa and we started
doing loa like crazies
and then we said like no no but we
should also do some
uh you know buying a property and we saw
we should also do hmos
and we started also doing a little bit
of service service accommodation and we
started doing
everything and then nothing was really
working
until i really uh
we really put the strategy together and
said we just have to focus
and and then uh i went into another
crash course just to have another
refresher and i've been into
other training as well uh and it is when
we have the
focus on doing things that everything
started to change
yeah so when you were actually at the
deal finding extravaganza
um where did you choose your patch where
were you you know
blackpool yeah and and did you go on to
buy properties in blackpool
uh yes i bought a first family led in
blackpool
and and a second one
hmo and we have now made an offer and
it's been accepted to buy
a third one directly vendor okay so the
strategies that you've chosen then is
to buy hmos yes you also turned
your two buy to let's that you had
previously into hmos is that right yes
into a propagation or now with a license
and and nice and then they're making
more money yes
yeah that's good to know um you've also
done
rent to rent yes how many rent events
have you currently got
five five rent events where where are
they in london we so we decided to focus
rental rent is in london and this is
with a company that's called
amply and then the property that i'm now
going to purchase
or i've been purchasing is in blackpool
which is my pachara so these are the two
things that we're now
now focusing on what was your first rent
to rent there was that the one that you
got because i know some of your
interventions you've done as joint
ventures where you've teamed together
with people
was the first one the one that you got
in your soul name yes okay
talk to me about that so how much money
did you have to put into that deal
that rent event deal in total including
the um
you know the furniture all the different
things you have to pay the fees
including the furniture it was around
five thousand pounds
about five so quite a lot of money for a
rent event
and that's in london yeah because this
one is in paddington so the rent is a
four bedroom
well three bedroom flat yes we made
that's a four bedroom
how long did it take to get that five
thousand pounds back
uh three months three months okay which
is
which is pretty good going you've still
got that today you're still renting that
one out
you've got four more rent events that
you've done in form of joint ventures
you've also done deal packaging and
selling
yes which is just but that that's not
been your focus though has it
see because i believe i believe angelica
that everybody should be a deal sorcerer
and here's what i think i'd love to know
what you think if you disagree
if you're trying to do everything all at
once like i'm gonna try and do this
strategy that strategy that strategy
that strategy you can be running around
let's say if you try and chase two
rabbits you'll catch none
however the flip side to that is a lot
of strategies
kind of cross you like like for instance
you've got rent to rent but you've also
got joint ventures
because you did the rent to rent as part
of a joint venture
so if you hadn't have known about joint
ventures you might have thought oh i
can't do this i haven't got the money to
put down
therefore i i'm going to take myself out
of the game but because you actually
don't know joint ventures
like you you're doing um rent to rent
but you're also using your experience of
hmos
to run your rent to rent business you're
also
i think this is why i think everyone
should be a deal sorcerer if you're a
property investor
you are going to be looking at
properties that are good that just don't
quite work for you
so i'm looking for hmm blackpool that is
no more than 150 grand with a 30 return
investment
you might find one that's amazing but
it's 250 grand
but the returns still there but you
think that's not quite for me
in which case sell it so one of the
things that you've been doing is you've
not been aggressively pushing your
deal packaging business when do you sell
a deal
when i go and look for a property for
myself right and if
it doesn't quite work for you but it's
really good is that when
that's when i pass it on or if you um
maybe you're looking for a property but
you find two and you think i can't quite
afford the second one that kind of thing
that's actually what happened the the
second property that i bought i went
there for like
uh i think was a week or something and
i view so many properties but i already
knew
exactly what i wanted so i was all the
properties that i was looking for was
already
like good properties that could fit my
strategy
and i put offers in i don't know maybe
12 properties i put offers on and then
three offers uh
after negotiation with all of them three
offers were accepted that i was like
i have three awesome properties i don't
know which one to use i swear to you i
couldn't
choose which one was the best because
the three of them were very very good
yeah so i literally ended up choosing
one of them
just because it was a private property
and now
thanks to actually another of your
videos on how to save
uh tax and you you send an email to my
newsletter to the newsletter saying like
there is ways to save tax and uh stamp
duty on private property something like
this
you didn't give all the all the
information but you gave me
probate properties stamp duty you can
save there is a way to save so i
literally searched sorry i just went out
of the topic but i just remember and
then
because of that we are now asking for
our
uh 3 000 pounds back
for the islam duty because there we go
and that was and that was free
information on a freaking newsletter
so if you can if you can get three
thousand pound tax back from the
newsletter just think what can happen
when you start but that's why though it
blows my mind though when people say
oh the training's so expensive it's like
it's an investment
yeah and i mean just on deal sourcing
alone
have you made your money back from what
you inve all the money you invested with
me oh yes
a lot of yeah many times over how much
of how many properties have you sold
four four so not a lot of houses but you
charge a decent amount
how much would you charge the package
and sell a deal 3 500.
okay so you've made 14 000 is that
correct in total just from
packaging and selling deals 14 grand
just oh i'm looking for myself i don't
it doesn't quite work for me
i'll just pass it on that's almost like
14 000 for doing
very very almost nothing because you
would have been looking at the houses
anyway
so but all you need to know is how to
speak to an investor the process the
paperwork
so it kind of blows my mind and you've
seen it because we've spoke about it
you've seen the
um the the the the losers
that fail and then go make you know go
on and make videos
and say don't do the training either
because they failed
or they haven't even done it they just
have their own
agenda did you see this stuff like
what's
what's your as someone that's on the
courses what what what do you think when
you see that kind of stuff
eh for me you know as i said i came from
a martial arts background where
it is a lot of respect to your ancestry
and to your mentors and to your teachers
i am a capoeira teacher so my students
also offer that respect to me
and for me when when i learn something
from you whether
you know it or not i will always be
grateful so i i have seen a lot of
videos of of uh
you know people that i actually met in
the course because
uh i was there in the course or or
people who
i know you you have thought in the past
and i just
feel even offended because it's
disrespectful
uh this is my opinion that just like if
if it didn't work for you
it doesn't mean that it doesn't work for
a lot of people but
the problem might be you know you not
the training so i i think that uh
property is definitely something that is
simple but not easy like it's simple
because
you know there is abc
in the uk because you know i am from
mexico compared to mexico
is very simple but it's not easy you
have to put a lot of work
like you have to really go and implement
the stuff
so but that person that you met though
at the training
did they do well in property or did they
fail
i probably they failed probably i mean
that
i mean but but but it's i don't know
it's i guess it's the minority and we
said this earlier it's the minority
because most people that succeed
they're so busy on their business
they're so busy but then the ones that
fail have the time to to go and troll
and
do and do videos um what's been the
um what's been the most challenging part
or
the most breakthrough where you learn
the most of your whole two years you've
done rent to rent you've done deal
packaging you've done hmos
you've done a lot of stuff like what's
been the most memorable over the last
two years
in terms of learning uh i think the
mindset
uh i would say actually two things
the first thing is is the mindset that i
always
heard this from other people and i
thought
well yeah but i have a positive mindset
i'm always being very passionate
but i also had a scarcity mindset and
and i might say that
i know but this is you know too good to
be true this is like
i don't know and and it's like you said
taking yourself
out of the game so it didn't happen
like that when i went to your first
training or the second
it is a process that is taking me a lot
a lot of time
and that's why i'm sure that if you
invite me another time in the future
i will be able to tell you much more of
a bigger things that i'm doing because
it it is only changing the last six
months maybe
that there are so
much out there and you just have to go
and grab it
so for me it's the mindset and the
second thing a more practical thing
is uh it is very important to do your
to-do list but it is much more important
to do your
not to-do list and when i learn this
it's very difficult to let things go
because good as
a book really nice book seven habits of
highly effective people say good is
enemy a lot of times
uh of great yeah and a lot of times
we're kind of hold on to the good
and we need to let that good go so that
great can
can happen you know so i literally had
to do my not to do list i'm not going to
do this anymore i'm not going to do this
anymore i'm not going to do this anymore
so much that we're now uh looking to get
a
va to do a lot of the admin so that i
can have more time to do more strategic
things so
we're in a recruitment process right now
that's great that's so good and i think
that
it's interesting because you you told me
you know you're making two and a half
thousand pounds a month
but that's after costs and stuff so
you've got joint venture partners to pay
you've got landlords to pay maintenance
and and everything
um what are you doing now because are
you still teaching kids
um i won't try and say it but um
brazilian yeah
are you still doing that yes and i
believe that i will
uh whether it's teaching practicing
having my own business
of my instructor to teach i think i will
always do it because that's
my passion i i use capoeira as a
transformation
tool for kids and adults but i have
stepped out a lot and this is one of the
things that i had to
compromise in order to focus more on
property and is i
believe the biggest and the toughest
decision for me to reduce the time there
to have my instructors in place so that
i can deliver the classes
and i only do a few classes my
my own or or i did more online classes
and now uh focus more on property you
believe that
mindset is a massive contributing factor
to success
yes definitely i i think that's so true
and that's so true because the thing is
everyone has access to this video right
now everybody has access to my
daily videos to the crash course to even
doing advanced training
so why is it that some people win and
some people lose
even when they have access to the same
information and i think it must be
due to that some people believe they can
do it
find solutions take massive action
other people take no action find
problems
find reasons in their mind as to why it
can't work and then it's no wonder
it's no it's no wonder that they fail so
i mean i don't know maybe 50 is
knowledge and 50
is action yes i i would say that
attitude well action yeah but and
really believing that it's going to
happen and not let the sequences
like for me the main difference is to
know that uh
some situations or where you're living
or what you have
is a stage and that stage can have time
frames
and not be part of your circumstances
for example if i let my
past you know most of
people that i was that i knew from my
childhood and
up until high school that i was living
in the same poor neighborhood
i don't know anyone i don't keep in
touch because
you know life has you know
changed significantly for for all of us
but i didn't let that part of my life
define who i am and who i want to be
or who i want to become so it's all
about understanding
who we are and that whatever we have or
whatever we are
living at a stage is is temporal
yeah we can we are bigger than that yeah
so it's a little bit more spiritual
because i am also spiritual but
that mindset of you know what whatever
you're living is just
a time frame yeah and you are not just
this
yeah uh i mean i think mindset and
attitude
discipline action for me i think it's
massively important
and it took you a long time to get to
here yeah you know it didn't happen fast
how long
was it after the dfa when you got your
first deal
uh i'm very bad with memory
uh was it fast though did it take a long
time no it took well
it took around
i think it's different in august and
first deal until next year may wow
i'm very slow but i think it's because
i'm thorough no yeah yeah it took it
took a while
and and some people would have said
after seven eight months
oh i've not done any deals this doesn't
work
it's not but actually you if you keep
going
you're going to get there in the end uh
i think persistence as well it's
something like some people can do it
real fast
some people are a bit longer some people
even longer um but if you look at it in
the grand scheme of things
from from where you were in 2018 to
where you are 2020
financially yeah it's a completely
different place
and bear in mind that when i went into
the dfe
i had zero money so it was on my credit
card i had zero money so i couldn't just
go and say i'm going to you know find my
first property and
or at least i thought that because i i
wasn't
very i knew the concept of join uh
business partner but i wasn't practicing
enough i didn't
implement it right away so that's why it
took me
another thing as well for anyone that's
watching this i mean all of our prices
for all of our courses are actually on
our website published so the dfe
all of the courses the academy which is
all of our training programs all
together which is about 12
000 pounds you didn't do the academy you
just did the deal finding extravaganza
which was one of the courses where you
might have invested maybe two and a half
thousand three thousand pounds
um but we talked about the academy and
you were expecting what
would you tell me what were you
expecting and what happened when we
spoke about the academy
well i um i
always received a lot of uh value from
your course so
when you invited people to you know to
to do an application for the academy
in the dfe i feel in mind because i was
like
you know what i'm i really know that i
want to do this
but the doubt was is this the right time
or or later
but i knew that i wanted to do the
academy so i put my application in and
then
you call us and your team people who had
feeling the application to go outside
and then i was expecting that
uh you know because i i you said
some i don't remember uh very well but
uh you selected who was
already sure and i i said look to be
honest i'm not
sure because i don't have the money to
do it
and uh i would really like to go first
and implement what i have learned here
and then come back and and then join
yeah and then you respond
you saw my application you saw the money
that i was making
and you're like fine do that
and i'm like hey can you please try to
convince me
you're expecting you wanted to be sold
to yeah i was like oh
yeah but but but the thing is you know
i could have persuaded you i'm sure i
could have been like put it on a credit
card or whatever
but but yeah you you'd already invested
a few thousand
onto the deal finding extravaganza and
um
and and and i thought you know what
you've not got too much money
i knew you were gonna i knew you were
gonna be driven and i knew you had a
good plan from the course
and uh and i was like yeah you just go
implement what you've done we'll talk
another date
um do you think that sometimes um
do you think that sometimes i get
unfairly criticized for heavy sales
you've been through it you've seen all
the sales every person can have
their own opinion for me and my
experience
uh i said to you i was like really are
you not going to come on
what is wrong with me why are not trying
to get me into the academy
so my experience is uh all positive
about you and i will always be grateful
i cannot speak for other people
experiences
but what i can speak is that if you have
a bad experience
you shouldn't you shouldn't go
publicly publicly to say bad things
about you because that's
their experience that's your experience
and
you are maybe putting other people
that could have more action or more
attitude and
and because of your opinion you whoever
is putting these videos
kind of blocking those new people that
you potentially do well
yeah so for me it's like if i have
something bad to say about someone and
that's
my personal opinion and my personal
experience i just don't say it
yeah there's no point because that's
that's part of
you know it could be that it's because
of me and not because of that person
so i just don't say it and that i don't
find it very
you know very well because there could
be many people that could really thrive
but if they listen to this they would be
put off
and that's why i'm so grateful to people
like you who are here right now
giving your experience which is a
positive experience which is to be
honest
you know this at the deal at the
advanced training most people in the
room are pretty happy
like most people uh the vast majority of
our students are really happy
what's the plans now they're moving
forward like what's the you you've
become financially independent you've
got um
uh four houses in you know already
you've got a fifth one
about to complete you've got five rental
rents uh you're making a full-time
salary from property
i know that for you this is just the
absolute beginning
and also as well do you think that your
first deal is your hardest because
you've made some really good
relationships as well through the way
which are looking promising to a lot
more deals talk to me a bit about that
well definitely the first one is the
hardest um
especially for me it was doing rental
rent because
buying a house there are sellers who
want to sell
and then you just go choose the the best
one for you negotiate the price
and and then make it happen so that was
easier the difficulty was getting the
money
to do that but that was easier however
during rental rent
a lot of landlords don't want or don't
know
that uh you know actually could be great
for them to be hands off
and having someone with passion and
knowledge
to run their their properties so
having a first rental rent was very very
difficult and
i think we got so many no's it just
doesn't matter you just have to keep
going
until uh we got our first deal
of a portfolio landlord and every time
that she has a property available and
she's actually buying more properties
she comes to us and say would this work
for you and then after
i met a person who i
really really admire and i am every time
i
go and have 10 minutes chat with him he
knows how much i appreciate it because
i met this person who is a portfolio
or as well but has more than 60
properties and like you know
buy property of a 3 million pound
property
like here and there and now to have
won his trust after
the second property that we managed for
him and that
he is now giving me a building to manage
with three three flats on the building
which he's a freeholder and he comes
with a
a new property to say with this work for
you
that means a lot to me and every time i
go and meet him
he knows because i told him but i'm sure
he didn't realize at the beginning
that just having this five minutes ten
minutes chat with him
like i'm doing with you and like we did
you know
off the camera is is great because for
you
saying something is a day-to-day but for
someone who is you know eager to learn
more
uh it's just a a very very
good thing so now things are finally
feeling a bit easier and we are
hiring this va as we speak now where i'm
making the recruitment process my
myself uh just to systemize so that i
can have
uh much more time for what i
now doing which is property development
which i'm
immersing into that world amazing
what's your strongest reason for doing
all this
oh well look as i said my background
was that i come from this poor
childhood and i was happy
but just to tell you a quick story
can i do that when i was in third year
in primary school i had a teacher that
was horrible
and this teacher used to smoke
before the assembly and he would gather
some kids
just to smoke the you know just to smoke
out
in their faces it was horrible and and
this was the kind of jokes and one time
he was written on
writing on the blackboard and i was
speaking the
is 50 60 students per class just very
very
busy and i was speaking to my friend
sergio
and he got very upset and he literally
turned around
and showed it toward us towards us and
and and just literally ask to put
our our hands in the front and literally
i just remember my tiny hands like this
and
in tears already and i just saw the rule
to me and sergio and
my wife is my son because although
i feel so happy and fulfilled with my
life
and i feel every day is a blessing
i just want that he has a different
opportunity
a different environment that his mindset
is you know
from day one for him is natural now
he's eight months old he doesn't realize
but he has gone
more than 20 viewings already
he's been in a refurbishing house in the
pandemic because no one wanted to
do it and he was in blackpool so me my
husband and him
went there and and my business partner
literally went there for a week
and then i came back and we were there
leaving for a month
and and he is in the middle of this of
this resiliency of
of this action to make things happen and
and of the opportunities so i want a
different
uh opportunity and a different
environment for him and the other big
reason
is i want to inspire other people
who have a hard life or who have
limited conditions and i want to leave
an example that
they can be a mother for their children
as my mom was with me
and doesn't matter the condition you can
do whatever you want that's so powerful
and
and i'm sure not only will your son be
a massively successful person and happy
person because of your great leadership
and role model but also
many other people will be touched when
they see your story and um
it's been amazing a couple years getting
to know you
and i'm excited about now walking into
property development with you as well
and um and doing some bigger some bigger
deals
because you got big energy i always say
the bigger your bigger your energy the
bigger your bank will be do you believe
that
i perfect i i am going to believe that
now
yeah the bigger yeah and even at the
crash course i'll say that i'll say look
you've got to throw yourself into this
and you're going to get rejected you're
going to get told no you're going to get
laughed at you
maybe if you become really successful
you're going to have people doing stupid
videos about you
you know but but but ultimately
you know massive action massive belief
and a massive reason why
for doing for doing what you're doing
how do you manage to juggle
your time like you say you moved to
blackpool for a month
just to do property because that's where
you've got an eight-year-old
son aaron eight months old sorry yeah
eight month old son aaron
um a husband you got married just after
we met at the deal finding extravaganza
so congratulations
on that and your and your and your new
son how do you manage the time
to be doing all this
look i just
don't have an option yeah so we don't
have anyone else to look after aaron
and i didn't want to put someone else
that
you know like a childcare or something
because
he was too little maybe in the short
future i
will consider but so far we have
time schedules with my husband so he he
has for example now
everything changes because aaron is
growing and changing the habits every
time every week but
right now the the current roles are for
example
eight to two and two to eight so someone
has aron
from eight to two and another person me
and him has aaron from two to eight
and i am signed up in a gym where you
can work
and it has a great environment so and
and it's a family club so i literally
take arm with me when it's
my turn from eight to two and he's there
and i just
i i think they laugh at me in the gym
because i get there with a
car seat the trolley together and a
little
chair and so i literally changed aaron
every
hour when he's a little bit crying so
from one to two
then i uh hold him so
he you know he is there with us the
whole time
yeah and when he is with my husband then
i have time
to just fully focus on what i and you
mentioned you mentioned about
environment
and you know the environment of the gym
and the environment of the training and
the environment of
i think environment is massively
important you might remember me saying
that the crash course uh or the dfa i
don't remember but i say environment is
stronger than willpower because if you
if
if you are around the right people
people that want you to win and are
cheering you on and supporting you and
are on the same page
that's going to keep you going whereas
if you're on your own and you're
isolated
um you know you might be really fired at
one day but you're just not going to win
you know and and it is true uh
we i decided to pay this gym is not
cheap i could be
as i was before in a 40 pounds per month
gym and i'm saving money on rent
because uh this is just a decision
in order to invest to keep investing the
money however in the gym i literally
said
i don't mind we're paying 250 pounds per
month
but because we want to be surrounded
with with
people with with that environment
you know aaron will have uh small
friends
who have uh wealthy families and
and that's the environment that i that i
really enjoy
right now being around winners yes and i
think that's what you what you find as
well coming to the crash courses and the
df that you're
the environment where people are like
you know i want you to win
and then um also as well the process
you know i i think it's really important
to know that life is not a journey life
is a process
and when you learn the process and
follow the process
you know a b c then figure out x y z
and walk that journey um which is what
which is what you've done what would be
your final piece of advice for someone
that's watching this that's thinking
maybe they're in the same position as
you when you
when we met where you didn't have any
money and you needed to put something on
your credit card
um like someone who's maybe starting out
but they've got the energy they've got
the fire they've got the
motivation what will be the first steps
that you would give them
um network yeah this is something that
is not easy for me in property
in capoeira or in fitness is natural
because
i've been doing it for 18 years but
in property it was unnatural it was like
scary and as soon as i get into the
crash course you asked me
who are you still in touch with people
you made in the first crash course i was
like
you know not talking to anyone so but
the the the second crash course that i
went was different in the dfe because i
still keep
a great friendship with uh
one person in particular and other
people just
contact so even if it's not comfortable
you have to network
because uh there are people who will
know your story your skills
and then you can you can both
collaborate
and and help each other well i think
people gleaning into this
this is the mindset right now of someone
who is successful
uh someone who is driven someone that's
actually not not going to be successful
but achieved it already
and i know you've got a long way to go
but what you've achieved to this point
is absolutely remarkable especially
considering where you've where you've
come from
so i just want to say massive massive
respect
thank you for coming to my home and um
it's been it's been great to be
part of your of your story it's amazing
to be here it's
uh i'm so grateful to to you and to what
you do
and uh for me i
want to have a way to to pay you back
well
i guess what do i say your success is my
oxygen so the fact that you've just
taken action and done it
makes me super happy so thank you thank
you guys i hope you enjoyed listening to
that i hope you're inspired i hope
you've got some really practical
golden nuggets if you want to see more
interviews
like the one with angie you can see them
right up here
also if you want to see just a really
practical video that's going to help you
in your property journey check this out
right here
and of course don't forget to subscribe
down here i'd really appreciate it if
you subscribe and of course
smash the like button i'll see you next
time